today on the Matt Walsh show the left
comes apart at the seams panics goes
into hysterics stop me if you've heard
this one before in this case because of
a case that's being argued at the
Supreme Court right now that deals with
abortion in fact we've reached the point
where Democratic senators are standing
on the steps of the Supreme Court while
cases are being argued calling out
certain justices by name and issuing
threats to try to intimidate them into
deciding the way that Democrats want
we'll talk about all of this but what I
really want to focus on especially is
the case itself and and and what it is
exactly that Democrats are freaking out
about because when you when you see what
they're freaking out about and and what
this what all the hysterics are really
about it shows it reveals the lie in the
claim that abortion is health care it
reveals that even they don't think that
so we'll we'll talk about all that also
five headlines including a very
disturbing headline about bigotry and
hatred and intolerance right here at the
Daily wire so you'll want to hear about
this apparently there's this guy named
Matt Walsh Matt Welsh something like
that never heard of him but this is a
pretty unsavory character and he's he's
especially said something that's pretty
pretty shocking and and startling so
we'll talk about that and then also
we'll get to your emails and there's
someone in the emails who thinks that
I'm very wrong about the coronavirus and
thinks in fact that what I've said about
the coronavirus is reckless and
dangerous is that true we'll talk about
that as well all of that and more coming
up but first a word from fairway you
know we i I've I've had the great
pleasure of eating some of fairways
products and I've had the sirloin steak
I've had the t-bone I've had various
cuts of pork the thing I love about it
is you don't have to be a great you know
I am a great chef let me just say that
but you don't have to be a great chef
it's just the the meat itself it doesn't
doesn't take a lot of seasoning it's
just all the flavors come out it's it's
delicious stuff and it's much better cut
of meat than what you're gonna find at
the grocery store and you're getting it
for a better price
well fairway is a family-owned grocery
chain that's been in business since 1938
fairways premium beef and all-natural
pork is raised by family farmers
hand-cut by highly experienced team of
fairway butchers from ribs to rib eyes
pork chops beef tenderloin buy the beef
tenderloin - that was delicious they're
certified heritage pork is crafted in
small batches by Midwest family farms
making it the most succulent pork that
you're ever gonna taste visit fairway
meat market calm you can select your
favorite meat products there like I said
this is this is way better than what
you're gonna find if you just go to your
local grocery store your local grocery
chain you get it from a better price as
well in fact this week my listeners can
get the Heartland package valued at $230
for just $99.99 so that's less than a
hundred bucks you're getting more than
50% off plus you get free shipping when
you enter Walsh at checkout the
Heartland package includes eight 8-ounce
all-natural boneless pork chops you get
six eight ounce USDA choice ribeye
steaks and then you get one
mouth-watering side dish loaded potato
baked gourmet cheesy corn brisket baked
beans whichever one you want to choose
that's more than 50% off the best meat
in America Plus free shipping
that's fairway meat market.com promo
code Walsh look for the heart wetland
package again fairway meat market.com
promo code Walsh look for the heartland
meat Heartland package ok now the
Supreme Court heard oral arguments
yesterday in the case of June medical
services verse Russo the case was
brought by abortionist in Louisiana who
are very upset about a state law that
would require abortion clinics to have
admitting privileges in local hospitals
in case now the reason for that in case
something goes wrong during an abortion
which can and does happen quite often
well you're gonna need to send the woman
to a real hospital so that they can be
treated now we're gonna come back to
this in a moment but that that's what
sets the stage and that's what this case
is about so this is not a case that
would overturn roe v wade it's not a
case that restricts abortion at all in
fact these are
some it does it's a it's a it's not a
case that that touches on abortion
itself at all it's a very basic
regulation on abortion clinics requiring
abortion clinics to take certain steps
to ensure the safety of their patients
but as we've learned time and time again
any restriction any regulation any law
any mere suggestion that comes within
500 miles of abortion is cause for panic
by abortion supporters and that's what
happened yesterday in DC speaker after
speaker got up at their at their pro
abortion rally and it just got crazier
and crazier as time goes on as it always
does with these leftist rallies so let's
start with a renee sherman who calls
herself the Beyonce of abortion
storytelling now I'm not sure what that
means exactly does it mean that when she
gives her speeches she lip-synchs I I
don't know exactly but let's let's watch
what she had to say and a special shout
out to where my people who had abortions
[Applause]
so as I said I had an abortion when I
was 19 it was honestly one of the best
decisions of my life I was simply not
ready to become a parent and that's
really all you need to know
okay you know what that that is perfect
in many in many ways to begin with it
once again completely annihilates the
claim that nobody celebrates abortion
okay we've got a woman standing at a
microphone shouting let's hear it for
all the people who have had abortions if
that's not celebrating abortion then
what is celebrating abortion what does
celebrating abortions look like and
sound like if not that I mean do you
need actual confetti raining from the
sky do we need the actual champagne to
be popped does there need to be a cake
with rainbow sprinkles that has the
phrase abortion is health care written
in frosting well that'd be absurd of
course nobody would ever oh wait right
yeah thanks thanks Miley so yes the left
celebrates abortion celebrates it all
the time there's no debate about that
but you can tell quite a lot from this
celebration that's what I want to focus
on because it's celebrating abortion but
this celebration is missing something
isn't it it's missing more than the
confetti in the cake it's it's it's
missing what's the word what's the thing
that you usually have in a celebration
joy happiness so even as she's shouting
let's hear it for all the people who had
abortions the expression on her face is
is empty there's no smile there's no
happiness in her eyes so it's just like
this is her face I should let's hear it
for all the people who have had
abortions complete not even the crack of
a smile it's it's it's not even close to
it and then the yeas and the Woo's from
the crowd are lifeless forced
unconvincing everyone's going whoa yeah
yes go us these are damaged guilt-ridden
bitter people who are trying to force
themselves to be happy about what
they've done but by pretending that
they're happy so this as I as I always
say with the celebration of abortion is
shot your abortion they're trying to
convince themselves they're not
convincing you not even talking to you
they're talking to themselves they might
as well they might as well just imagine
every time you see this kind of thing
just imagine a mirror and they're
talking into the mirror this is this the
the Beyonce of abortion storytelling she
probably gets up every single morning
and looks in the mirror and says let's
hear it for all the people who had
abortions we're happy yes we're very
happy what it never works it's a fake it
till you make it strategy but they're
never gonna make it they're never gonna
be happy until they admit to themselves
that that what they did was evil and
horrible and horrendous and hideous and
then at that point now I'm not saying
that a woman who has abortion can never
be happy or satisfied in her life again
I'm not saying that I'm saying once you
begin just like with anything else that
you that you're feeling guilty about
that you've done even something that's
less serious than killing your own child
but if you want to get past it if you
want to get past that guilt you're not
gonna get past it by repressing it by
pretending trying to convince yourself
it was okay that's a rationalization
you'll spend your whole life
rationalizing it it has to begin by
saying yes this was wrong
there was a horrible thing you start
with that you face it you confront it
you admit and then you can finally begin
to heal women can find healing after
abortions but it's not gonna be a
healing through denial there's no such
thing as as healing through denial it
doesn't happen so for them as long as
they're trying to fool themselves it's
they're not going to heal speaking of
joyless and lifeless here's Rasheeda to
leave this past year I realize my my my
are they obsessed with our bodies how we
talk how we look what we stand for I
mean this type of policing of our bodies
is so interconnected to all the social
justice movements all around the country
I represent the third poorest
congressional
district in the country this issue is an
economic justice issue this issue is a
racial justice issue and let me tell you
this obsession with our bodies
you know I in the legislature in the
Michigan Legislature for six years used
to save people to people yo-yo you know
what you're so freakin obsessed with
what I decide to do with my body
maybe you shouldn't even want to have
sex with me we have over our bodies to
push back and use that power insane
enough is enough
we won't stand by for you to
commercialize for you to profit for you
to do all the things you do to what to
make us less than in this country no yo
yo check it
maybe you shouldn't want to have sex
with me well Rasheeda I will respect
your wishes on that front I I will
done and done okay that's you you got it
no argument from me in fact this this
might be the only thing that Rasheeda
Talib has ever said that both sides can
agree on indeed I believe we have forged
a a bipartisan consensus on this
particular issue this is the issue that
will unite the entire country that's
coming from Rasheeda Talib I never
thought who ever thought that she would
be the one to say something and
everybody in America can unite in one
voice and say yes we agree you know I've
noticed something feminists in one
breath insists that their bodies are
none of our business
yet as soon as they finish saying that
they get right back to talking
incessantly about their bodies divulging
details we didn't ask for and we didn't
want to hear shouting about their sex
lives constantly shoving it in our faces
while telling us it's none of our
business all of these details I'm
telling you about my sex life are none
of your business yes I agree I told
he agrees so shut up how about that
there's a good solution and that brings
us speaking of people who need to shut
up that brings us to Chuck Schumer Chuck
Schumer of course who by the way has the
distinction of among all US senators
looking the most like a Batman villain
but yesterday he decided to really take
that role as the bat as the Batman
villain seriously and I'm gonna play
that that clip for you in just a second
if you haven't seen this this is all
it's nearly unbelievable it gets right
up to the edge of you can hardly believe
that even a Democrat would say this but
we'll play that for you just a second
but first let's check in with our good
friends over at Tommy John you know when
it comes to comfort especially comfort
beneath your outer garments shall we say
there's underwear and then there's Tommy
John the revolutionary clothing brand
that's redefined comfort for Americans
everywhere including myself to put it
simply Tommy John doesn't give an F that
is they give three FS don't just give
one they give three fabric fit and
function I think all of those things
you're gonna want when it comes to
underwear Tommy John obsessives over
every little detail in stitch and you
can really tell I could tell you know
when you when you see the product when
you when you put it on you can tell that
this is they've put a lot of time into
you know they're not just they're not
just throwing something together this is
every every stitch counts by using
proprietary fabrics that perform like
nothing you've ever worn before as a
result Tommy John's men's and women's
underwear sport a no wedgie guarantee
comfortable stay put waist bands which
is important aspect of wearing underwear
and a range of fabrics that are soft
feather-light moisture wicking
breathable designed to move with you not
against you and that means that there's
no bunching there's no riding up and
Tommy John's is so confident in the
underwear that if you don't love your
first pair you can get a full refund
with their best pale your best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guarantee
you give if you if you if you want to
give three apps about your underwear and
upgrade with Tommy jobs again that's
fabric fit and function then you want to
go to Tommy John's hurry - Tommy John
komm slash walls for 20% off your first
order that's Tommy John calm slash Walsh
for 20% off your first order Tommy John
calm slash Walsh go there now ok Chuck
Shumer auditioning for his role in the
next Batman film this is what he had to
say I want to tell you Gorsuch I want to
tell you Cavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price you
won't know what hit you so what what has
happened here just just to review is
Chuck Schumer United States Senator has
called out Cavanaugh and Gorsuch by name
and says that they have released the
whirlwind they will quote pay the price
and they won't know what hit them
now these remarks have provoked
condemnation for many people rightfully
so including Chief Justice Roberts and
Donald Trump President Trump
Schumer spokesman has tried to justify
this and has said this is what he said
it it was speaking of the threat saying
it was a reference to the political
price Republicans will pay for putting
them on the court and a warning that the
justices will unleash major grassroots
movements on the issue of reproductive
rights against the decision so it's a
political price BS bull nonsense
political pipe price that Republicans
will pay well then that's what you would
have said you will you would have said
I'm talking to you Republicans you've
unleashed the whirlwind etc etc he
didn't say that he called out two
justices by name they're not politicians
they're not elected justices don't pay
political prizes what is a Supreme Court
justice care about a grassroots movement
a grassroots movement can do nothing to
the Supreme Court it makes no difference
to a Justice what happens to the
political party or what the grassroots
movements are doing they stay in their
position regardless they still decide
cases so to claim that a reference to a
political price that a lifetime
appointed judge will pay that
that claim is incoherent by definition
that's sort of the whole point of them
being lifetime appointees is so that
they can't pay political prices and they
can't be threatened with political
repercussions that is the whole point
Schumer is just too much of a rat too
much of a coward to stand by his own
words this was obviously a threat an
attempt at it's intimidation and I'm not
saying that Schumer is is hatching some
sort of plan to send assassins after
after Kavanaugh and Gorsuch although
maybe you can't put it past them but I'm
not saying that I think it was this was
from Schumer his intention was for it to
be a sort of vague general intimidating
statement that hey you better watch out
I'm whipping up this crowd I'm making
them angry and and you know you know you
don't want to have a call you don't want
to have a whole crowd of people a whole
bunch of people that hate your guts
that's all I'm saying you might pay a
price for that not saying what kind of
price just there might be a price it
doesn't you don't have to be a detective
to put the dots together to understand
what he's saying and and again if if
it's not a physical price then what kind
of price are you talking about we've
already established that it can't be a
political price so tell me what you mean
he can't say so saying that it's some
sort of physical intimidation that's the
only reasonable interpretation now I'm
not a legal expert but I'm pretty sure
it's not legal to threaten a Supreme
Court justice in order to influence his
decision in a case it's not legal to
threaten judges in general to influence
their decisions in cases or for any
other reason and and there are actually
specific laws against uttering threats
on Supreme Court grounds which is what
Chuck Schumer just did us code reading
now from the website of a Cornell
lawsuit suit law school says it is
unlawful to discharge a firearm firework
or explosives set fire to a combustible
make a harangue or oration or
loud threatening or abusive language in
the Supreme Court building or on grounds
loud threatening abusive language it's
exactly what you heard there it's
against the law
Schumer broke the law period he should
be arrested for it and that's not a joke
it shouldn't sound like a joke
hey I know that's that's that's the
point we've gotten to in this country
where I say a senator should be arrested
for breaking the law and it sounds like
I'm joking it sounds ridiculous the the
the the thought of a u.s. senator facing
any kind of legal penalty for breaking a
law is almost funny it makes you laugh
the thought of it well it shouldn't be
funny he's not special
he's not above the law even if he's even
if that's been the way it's worked it
shouldn't work that way and he should be
arrested for it I don't want to hear
just verbal condemnation from
Republicans yeah that too but why not
send the police to arrest this guy who
just threatened Supreme Court justices
on the steps of the Supreme Court held
circle back here for a moment because I
want to emphasize what this is actually
about like I said at the beginning this
is not a case that would overturn roe v
wade it's not anything close to that
it's a case centering around a law in
one state that would require abortion
clinics to have admitting privileges B
that is the ability to admit patients
into the hospital and the reason for
that is is very obvious if there's a
medical emergency you need to be able to
send the patient to the hospital and you
don't want to just put them in their car
and-and-and say well go to go to the
nearest emergency room and wait there
you'll want to do that you need to get
them right into the hospital and that's
what the admitting-privileges list is
for now any other outpatient medical
clinic Surgery Center is going is going
to have admitting privileges at a local
hospital this is a very standard
regulation that healthcare clinics face
and in any other I say other in quotes
any other health clinic wouldn't object
to it because they would say yes well of
course we should it should have that
so this reveals the lie now they say
abortion is healthcare just like you saw
a Miley Miley's cake their abortion is
health care that's what they tell us
Ilhan omar sent out a tweet yesterday
abortion is health care period that's
what they say
now you say abortion is health care my
question is a health care okay well then
what illness or injury is it treating if
something is healthcare then it should
be treating some sort of malady some
sort of illness or injury and what what
does what does abortion treat exactly I
know the answer it treats pregnancy but
pregnancy is not a malady it's not an
illness it's not a it's not an injury so
it's not healthcare but you claim that
it is if you're a pro-abortion person
okay well then if these are healthcare
clinics let's treat them like any other
healthcare medical clinic they should
have the exact same regulations you said
it so they say it's it's it's health
care these are medical clinics we say
okay well then let's give it the same
regulations oh we can't do that that's
an attack on women would you ever say
you know that whatever regulations a the
orthodontist office has to has to abide
by would we call that an attack on
patients of the orthodontist clinic
would we say that health and safety
guidelines of orthodontists that those
guidelines are an attack on the patience
of the orthodontist clinic makes no
sense it's the exact opposite of an
attack on the patients it's meant to
protect the patients so they don't of
course believe what they say themselves
all right let's move on to headlines
number one
CNN reports a cruise ship passenger died
from coronavirus less than two weeks
after he returned home marking
California's first death as the disease
sickens people in 15 states the death
reported Wednesday was linked to the
Grand Princess cruise ship and was the
first coronavirus fatality outside
Washington State where 10 people have
died the cruise ships being held off the
California coast so federal health
officials can screen the people aboard
some of whom were on an earlier cruise
with the California victim the
unidentified victim was 71 and had
underlying health conditions now we
should note that those deaths in
Washington State are at a nursing home
which has been particularly hard-hit by
the illness this again underscores the
point that the virus is mostly killing
people who are elderly or already sick
which doesn't make it any less sad it's
still a tragedy of course but it does
put into perspective who is actually at
risk here of dying or becoming seriously
ill from the corona virus and that's
what this we need to have perspective we
need to have an appropriate in
proportion risk assessment of the corona
virus and we'll get back to that in in
emails in just a minute
number two elizabeth warren supporters
are not taking her humiliation and
failure lying down they've gone into the
arsenal of weapons and they've pulled
out the only weapon they have which of
course is to accuse everybody of sexism
that's all they've got the s bomb that
they drop on everybody yes because the
only conceivable reason that anyone
could ever have for a disliking
Elizabeth Warren is if they hate all
women imagine thinking that imagine
imagine thinking that Elizabeth Warren
Elizabeth Warren is such an appealing
figure so objectively appealing that the
only reason you could ever have for
disliking her is if you have a disdain
for all women in general like that's the
only possible explanation now I've seen
a lot of arguments like this one this is
from June Diane Raphael who's an actress
apparently and she says she says stop
telling your daughters they could be
President when you are unwilling to vote
for a woman president unwilling to vote
for a woman president that's what you
hear from Warren supporters I do why are
you all unwilling to vote for a woman no
we're just unwilling to vote for that
woman it's not women it's that woman
you know so this is like saying stop
saying you like food if you're unwilling
to eat the spoiled yogurt in my fridge
I mean you say you like food but then I
served up a nice heaping bowl of mouldy
sour spoiled rancid yogurt and you
wouldn't eat it so it seems like you've
got a problem with food of course that
makes no sense it's it's it's it's not
food it's that particular dish you've
put in front of me it's not women it's
that particular woman you've put in
front of us as voters by the way watch
how quickly all of these arguments
disappear when nikki Haley runs for
president in 2020 for which she probably
will I imagine what all of this stuff
goes out the window immediately number
three and some bad news today
unfortunately next month an asteroid
that could be as large as two and a half
miles wide will fly right by the earth
just missing us so close damn it
that was such a tease all these
asteroids you know it's a real problem
in the asteroid community they're all a
bunch of teases just to give you an idea
of what we're missing with this this
thing that could be the solution to all
of our problems an asteroid that's a
mile wide hitting Earth that you know
they would be about thirty thousand
miles an hour that would have the impact
of 1 million Megaton bombs or it would
be 10 it would be 10 million times more
destructive than an atomic bomb pretty
much no matter where it hits then you'd
be looking at global destruction so just
to give some perspective on that an
asteroid that's only a fraction of that
size an asteroid that's the size of say
a town house would be enough to flatten
an entire city it would be like you know
what it would be the effect of the
Hiroshima bomb basically so close but no
cigar
maybe next time number four and but of
course the good news is that at least
the world will be wiped out by climate
change either way you know in 10 years
so number four and the next big
primaries in Michigan next week an
article in political argues that Biden
could finish finish off Bernie there
Bernie won Michigan in 2016 looks like
by the according to the polls he's seven
points
right now so if you lose as Michigan
then then the argument is that it's it's
kind of over for them I hate to keep
beating this drum but if Biden wins the
nomination and then the general we're
gonna be in a position this is a serious
thing we're gonna be in a position of
not knowing really who's in charge
because Biden is in the middle of a
precipitous mental decline it's only
gonna get worse so what happens when he
has full-blown dementia does anybody
know what do we do how will we know will
they tell us when Biden loses his mind
are they gonna is can we trust the
administration that tell us that that's
what's happening and what do we do from
there and and and what about on the way
it's a completely losing his mind at
what point do we is the line drawn and
and we say okay we've got it we got to
get him out of it well nobody out what
we are we are entering into uncharted
territory so I guess we're gonna find
out
finally disturbing headline here look at
this it says daily wire host calls for
hosts call for extreme measures
including violence against drag queens
this is for media matters of course the
article says The Daily wires Matt Walsh
and Michael Knowles called for drastic
measures to prevent drag queens from
being around children with Walsh
explicitly calling for violence against
them by saying quote real men should
kick a drag queen quote out on his ass
and call the police it's not funny it's
very serious a Walsh also said that the
adults in a room in which a drag queen
danced in front of a child quote should
be going to prison and Knowles called on
quote the arm of the state to stop this
The Daily wires official YouTube account
uploaded video of Walsh's extreme
comments made during the Matt Walsh show
podcast which has received more than
31,000 views the video cuts off before
Walsh's explicit calls for violence but
includes his claim that the adult should
be arrested for letting a drag queen
perform in front of a child wow this is
pretty horrifying stuff and I personally
won't stand for this kind of bigotry I
don't know
this Matt Welsh guy is I've heard of
Michael Knowles no surprise that he's
saying bigoted stuff it's exactly what
you'd expect from him but you know what
they're actually were referring to was a
video where a drag queen dances
suggestively for a little girl while she
looks on horrified and all the adults in
the room are applying so this wasn't
calling for violence against drag queens
generally it was calling for men to take
action to defend children from sexual
grooming and abuse that was the point
okay the point was if a child is being
abused exploited harassed any decent man
any real men would step in step up and
put a stop to it but still yes horribly
bigoted very dangerous only a bigot only
a bigot would be opposed to the sexual
harassment of a child that's the only
reason that anyone could be opposed to
it I cannot think of any other reason
why a person would be upset about this
there just isn't any other reason
honestly and and don't worry this is not
about normalizing pedophilia I mean
we're we're just we're only accusing
people of bigotry if they're outraged by
the sight of a cross-dressing man and
booty shorts dancing for a child no
we're just that's it we're shaming
people for being against that but oh
that's that doesn't logically end in the
normalization and defense of pedophilia
not at all no no no no no no I know it
really seems like that's where it's
headed but it's not and and if you ever
say that you're a bigot too anyway again
whoever said those things whoever that
was I denounce it personally disavow it
and I just I don't want any part of it
all right we're gonna move on to your
daily cancelation but before we do you
know the daily wire zone Andrew Clavin
who you know and love has released the
second entry in his excellent another
Kingdom trilogy Austin Lively once just
an out of luck Hollywood screenwriter is
now a chosen hero caught between two
worlds and dual quests in both Los
Angeles California and the magical media
medieval word or
of Galliano you could experience this
adventure yourself you've heard the but
you've heard the podcast of course the
podcast is wildly popular millions of
people have have watched it and I know I
have but you could get the book today on
Amazon Andrew Klavan is doesn't if
you've never read any of his books it
shouldn't surprise you to learn that
he's a just a great natural writer makes
me kind of jealous myself as someone who
who attempts to write that they
obviously come so naturally to him so I
would absolutely recommend going going
to get that book right now on Amazon now
for your daily cancellation and it's the
Huffington Post
on the chopping block today so come on
down Huffington Post yesterday
Huffington Post published this article
it is it says I'm demisexual here's what
I want you to know I was 23 when I
finally discovered there was a word for
my experiences and feelings and the
article consists of a long personal
history a memoir of this woman who's
coming out as demisexual very brave very
bold very beautiful and after this long
preamble about her romantic life we
finally get to this she says my friends
would gush over the cute guys in school
and I played along I trusted them
entirely so I figured if they thought
those boys were cute they had to be
right I never fully understand
understood what it was that was so
appealing to them they were usually nice
but I had no idea why my friends wanted
to kiss them I knew close to nothing
about most of them there was no inkling
of sexual or physical attraction to
people I didn't know very well even
after puberty and now as an adult I
realize that's exactly what
demisexuality is I'm attracted to
someone
only after I develop a deeper emotional
connection with them I can count on one
hand the number of men I've kissed in my
life or have been attracted to and I
have no problem with that number in no
way do I feel that I've missed out
because to my bodies inclination I'd
much rather have a seven hour long
conversation with someone than be
physically intimate with them so there
you go that's demisexuality women who
prefer to develop deep emotional
connections women who would rather talk
just want to talk you know would rather
do that to be physically intimate they
are demisexuals so in other words every
woman is a demisexual it's a 1x2 every
woman is on the demisexual spectrum
let's put it that way you know there may
there may be varying degrees but every
woman is in that is in that range so
like yeah call me crazy but I and I
don't mean to try to authorize or erase
demisexuals far be it for me far be it
for me to be a demi foe to be Demi
phobic but I really think we don't need
a separate word for this you know I
think just woman is fine because we all
kind of get it we know that that's part
of the part of the thing and even if it
wasn't so common right we still wouldn't
need a word for it it's not a it's not
its own sexuality it's not a whole new
thing uh you know someone who's
attracted to another person based more
on their personality that's not that's
it's pretty normal it's just you don't
need a new word for that there are some
people who find a sense of humor to be
especially attractive there are other
people who don't care quite as much
about that we don't need an we don't
need a name for that
we don't need to call them humo sexuals
as fun as that would be to have that
label out there so this becomes a
problem for the LGBT narrative actually
because we're told that LGBT folks are
persecuted and oppressed yet we also see
how people are positively desperate to
be a part of this to be a part of the
LGBTQ Club everybody wants to get into
the abbreviation the holy sacred
abbreviation everybody's trying to barge
their way in trying to find a way inside
know I'm a demisexual I'm gonna you know
I've LGBTQ D there's D in there
somewhere
people are so determined not to be plain
old heterosexual that they're finding
ways to slip out of the heterosexual
camp it's like at night they slip out
and they try to sneak into the LGBTQ
camp
trust me I'm in the heterosexual camp
and every morning
it's like we wake up and we do roll call
and we find that someone else has
defected it's very sad sometimes we can
see them running away we'll see a guy
kind of running away over the hill and
we'll shout to him we'll say hey hey
where are you going what are you doing
and he'll shout back said oh sorry I'm
uh yeah I'm leaving I got it I
discovered that I'm I'm actually it
turns out I I'm a blonde a sexual light
I prefer women with blonde hair so I'm
blonde to sexual I'm going over to the
LGBT I'm getting in there on it be it's
part of the thing but blindness sexual
isn't a thing though it's not a
everybody likes blonde women come back
and then they disappear over the horizon
and all the straight men mourn the loss
of our brother in arms and then we put
on our cargo shorts and we'd carry on
with our lives anyway this just doesn't
seem like the kind of thing that would
happen if LGBT people were really
persecuted I don't think people would be
trying since generally when there's a
persecuted minority you don't generally
have people claiming to be in that
category even when they're not that's
not usually what happens right
finally let's go to emails Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Adam says good
morning theocratic fascist overlord I
work for a gym focusing on being a
Family Center we have multiple locations
in central Maryland as you know Maryland
is a very left-leaning area and so the
place I work is as well I was recently
asked to replace the signage for our one
off restrooms currently have they have
the kind of sign you see on any restroom
the little outline of a man or woman I'm
beginning I'm being asked to find signs
that say all gender restrooms like the
picture attached and there's a picture
of the sign since I believe the truth
and know that there are only men and
women should I not go along with this I
see an easy compromise and simply
putting a sign that says restroom but
I'm not sure how to present this without
having the whoa crowd jump on me I
cannot wait till you assume your true
mantle as ruler of this insane world we
don't have to deal with things like this
thank you for your response
well Adam so you say one off wet
restroom so I assume you mean so that's
a single person is that what I mean I
don't know what one off restroom in so
if we're talking about single person
restrooms then first of all I don't
think there's any problem here I think
there's any moral quandary now if it was
a multiple multi person restroom and
they were trying to get you to to set it
up so that any gender can go in there
then then I think that's a situation
where you have to say no that's I'm not
doing that that's crazy it's dangerous
but there's no reason for a single
person restroom to be to be this is the
one compromise I'll give to the to the
other side of this discussion when it
comes to the restrooms yes would single
person restrooms there's no reason for
them not to be available to to to men or
or women right because there's only one
person in there at a time so I you know
I don't I wouldn't see necessarily see a
problem with putting all gender on there
yeah it's it should both gender should
be the phrase all gender makes it sound
like there's more than two but it
doesn't necessarily mean that because
all you know so all genders well there's
only two so all means two so I you know
I wouldn't necessarily see III don't
think it's something you need get
yourself fired over and I don't think
that they're asking you directly to deny
the truth if they were then then I think
that's where you take a stand but but
but they're not you know putting that
sign on there is just a little bit of PC
so it's silly ridiculous PC pandering
but it doesn't really matter anyway okay
let's move on this is from Noah says
Matt you're wrong about the corona virus
your comparison of the corona virus and
the flu is faulty and shows your
scientific ignorance the corona virus
has a much higher mortality rate two to
three percent it spreads before symptoms
are shown and it has different ask
different effects on the body trying to
minimize this epidemic is irresponsible
and dangerous you really are wrong about
this and you owe it to your listeners to
do better research before spouting off
about a subject like this okay no I'm
not sure you understand
my point first of all you don't know
that the mortality rate of coronavirus
is 2 or 3% it almost certainly is not
now I know that's the reported mortality
rate but as I explained on the show a
couple of days ago
that's the mortality rate for reported
cases so people that have the symptoms
they go to the doctor they get tested
they they come back positive if they
recover ok that's someone who's going to
count against the mortality rate so 2 or
3 percent to this point of people who've
reported who have tested positive for it
have been reported as positive for
coronavirus have died most of them in
China
the issue is that in most cases in the
vast majority of cases the symptoms for
coronavirus are very mild it's going to
be the symptoms of a cold fever cough
right runny nose that that kind of thing
which means almost certainly I can't say
this for sure but it just it stands to
reason common sense would tell you that
there have probably been many thousands
of people who've had the corona virus
but that it was just mild symptoms so
they didn't go and get tested for it
especially before this was all over the
headlines and recovered and yet just
nobody knows nobody ever found out about
it so they don't they don't count
against the mortality rate which is why
the real mortality rate is almost
certainly a lot less than than 2 or 3
percent I don't know what it is but
neither do you
second my point about the flu is not to
say that they're the same or equally as
dangerous I agree that having the corona
virus is probably more dangerous than
having the flu we don't know the
mortality rate again but it probably is
it's it's it seems like it'd be a good
guess to say that the mortality rate the
real mortality rate is probably still
higher than it is for the flu so if you
had to choose between having the corona
virus or the flu I think you would
choose the flu but this is about risk
assessment yes you are more likely to
die from the corona virus if you have it
but you are much much much much much
much much more likely to get the flu and
not the coronavirus which means that as
you stand there right now as a healthy
person you are much much much much much
much much more likely to die of the flu
than you are to die of the corona virus
or although chances are you're not gonna
die of either what you're gonna die of
something but probably not one of those
millions of people get the flu hundreds
of thousands died of it across the world
every single year
those numbers are exponentially greater
than it is for the corona virus right
now so it's risk assessment what's the
risk that you get the corona virus very
small if you do get it what's the risk
that you die of it again very small so
it's a small risk on top of a small risk
what's the risk of you getting the flu
much greater right what's the reason for
stipulating this well it because it's
good to have a healthy perspective on
the dangers that we face as people our
survival depends on it on being good
risk Assessors we have to be able to do
that not because we should be dismissive
of the corona virus but just because
it's smart to be more more focused on
the things that are more likely to be
threats to us unfortunately the problem
is that the media sensationalism often
you know gets us worried not just what
the corona virus but in general we get
worried about things that are that are
on the fringes as far as threats that
are probably not going to affect us but
the media focuses on those things
because they're uncommon and that makes
them more sensational and and more
interesting to report on so we get
focused on that and oftentimes at the
expense of focusing on things that are
more important and that's why you have
the I think rather absurd dichotomy of
people are going out and buying surgical
masks because of the corona virus yet
yet haven't even gotten their flu shot
Bethany Mandel on Twitter made a great
analogy she said that it's like parents
who worry about their their kids being
kidnapped so they don't let their kids
play outside on their own yet a lot of
those very same parents will put their
kids in the car seat and not
properly and not properly hook in the
car seat you know when you put the kid
of the car so you need to have the strap
up closer to the up on their chest you
need to make sure that it's tight a lot
of parents just throw their kid in the
car seat you know buckle it up don't
even worry about adjusting it and your
kid is much much much more likely to die
in a car accident because he's not
properly strapped in than he is to die
from being kidnapped now if your kid is
kidnapped god forbid then he in that
scenario in that context is of course
gonna be at a much greater risk than a
kid who's in an in a improperly
installed car seat but your kid is
almost certainly not going to be
kidnapped especially by a stranger
most of the kidnappings that you hear
about and it's still very rare but most
of the kidnappings that you hear about
are are you know custody disputes and
that sort of thing it's parents
kidnapping their own kids and a custody
dispute well if we're talking about
kidnapping by a stranger like a kid
that's abducted off the street in a van
or or someone breaks into a house and
steals a kid out of the window those
sorts of things have happened but the
chances of it happening to your kid are
vanishingly small it it almost
definitely won't happen yet as parents a
lot of us were more worried about that
you know I can be guilty of this before
I go to bed tonight I check every single
lock in the house I'm checking the
windows on the fear in the back of my
mind that someone's gonna sneak in the
house another night and steal one of my
kids meanwhile now I I am I am pretty I
think I am pretty good about the car
seat too but but still I this is
something that it's a threat that takes
up space in my mind even though the
chances of that happening it's like I
could leave the door wide open every
single night and almost definitely
nobody will come in and steal my kit
yeah I still worry about it much more
than is reasonable to
bad risk assessment and so I think that
we should try to have an appropriately
calibrated risk Assessor in our brain so
that we understand what things are
actually threats to us and we focus more
on them and a little bit less on the
things that are not really threats or
are not likely to be threats that's my
point okay
we'll leave it there as I remind you
again about the Church of coward which
is in stores now and I I appreciate all
the great feedback I've gotten on this
book it's a book that's very personal to
me as any book is when you write it but
this is a book that I put a lot into it
so I appreciate everyone that's bought
it and read it and given it some some
thought and so I hope you'll you'll
you'll give it a read as well go to
Amazon right now and pick it up and
we'll leave it there thanks a lot for
watching the show everybody Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]